what's happening there reject nation we
got a little trailer behind the scenes
look at shazam fury of the gods we got
john here we got koi zhandro here our
comic book expert aficionado
shazam yeah are you more excited for
shazam for the gods are black adam oh
okay shazam is my favorite dc eu film
and that's going to cause some
controversy but i think black adam is
going to change things more nostalgizing
going shazam too all right it's a hard
decision because chris brosnan is a
doctor of fame i got that's almost
enough alone it's plugging these
headphones that i've been holding in
camera for you guys
[Music]
i mean this movie is just so fun already
the bts the fun here
hello my name is zachary levi i
and i play shazam
family established something very
special on the first movie and and
shazam period the guys we expand on that
[Music]
now they have to balance their life with
being superheroes this is where you hang
out with your superhero friends isn't it
[Music]
these goddesses
come to our world
our incredible new villains
[Music]
[Music]
when i talk about upgrades you got an
upgrade a huge upgrade in the suit
bigger action sequences bigger set
pieces we go from athens to philadelphia
we go from the rock of eternity and the
library of eternity to the realm of the
gods so
environments that we'll never explore
holy
[ __ ] this looks huge
at all and they're like we gave you
money this time
it did well okay we actually care about
the gods
[Music]
damn
hates the excitement
[Music]
well you know you do get a very
different impression from that one
because the last one is you know big
meets superhero it's very like personal
and grounded with like you know of
course you got your savannah in there to
ascend it to like comic book movie and
yeah i mean shazam is a pr there's been
several interpretations of shazam i've
read i read quite a few of shazam
actually i don't know how to quite i
mean i'm excited for it in a lot of ways
at the same time like this looks like
it's going more traditional superhero
movie as opposed to the special little
niche it found yeah
because i'm not getting the is jekyll
and grazer in here did i like totally
visit the top of the building talking to
the guy okay
stay focused cause he was my favorite
part
i focused way more on them as the
shazamily adult forms yeah okay yeah i
mean at least one shot i mean there's a
lot to look forward to from being pretty
well acquainted with the shazamily and
uh i i like i like it don't get me wrong
it's just such a it seems like such a
leap yeah from and this is behind the
scenes after maybe they're trying to
sell us on the fact that this is bigger
yeah i mean there's a lot to be looking
forward to i'm excited about the
mythology and everything i just i don't
want to lose that real personal touch
that the last one had that's what made
it so special it definitely felt like it
went from being an underdog story about
the back home versus the duality of
becoming a hero into globetrotting like
they leave yeah
i mean it goes a lot of places it's so
much bigger
yeah it almost feels like a sword and
sandal superhero movie which can totally
work but it's interesting that like i
don't i didn't see asher in there that's
what i was thinking i'm not jack dylan
yeah you notice like you you've got the
the more authentic superhero suits where
you know zach doesn't have the padding
it's actually his gains which i respect
but it's also like you're leaning into
the more adult heroes and i love that
mary is playing both young and hero mary
like you have the same actors playing
that but it does look like now that
they're aged up they're in their hero
form more so maybe there is less of the
more contained because they're all
finding out what it's meant to be so
powerful but that does change the entire
dynamic of the film yeah that's one
thing i really liked about the shazam
lee it like from the comics i've read
like a lot but i've read it quite a few
and every time i've read one it's
usually they are like still orphans yeah
oh and they're still i mean there's like
several versions like even revisiting
flashpoint the other day was they all
form one unit right yeah and that was
one version of it this time they're all
separate which is more of the the recent
iteration yeah the current shazam run
has a lot less of the the de-powered
thems yes so i still like when they're
still
orphans trying to deal with this thing
yeah i find that more appealing and this
was like all the adults and all the
god-like stuff so i don't know john how
are you feeling
i do agree with you i actually was
rather enthralled and excited
the
prospect of bringing in more uh
creatures and characters from especially
like greek mythology and going further
into that because i think what the first
movie did was they set up this neat idea
with the seven deadly sins but the seven
deadlies were mostly just big monsters
kind of themed off their sin but not
really fully down the rabbit hole of
what those could be so i feel like maybe
what they're gonna do is at least
enhance that element make it more of a
monster movie in some ways borrow from
david sandberg's you know obvious horror
background that he got to strut a little
bit of in the previous movie but
thinking too about just the settings
they're gonna be in that's perfect
opportunity for you to call upon some of
those horror shops and to really
accentuate just these locations we're
going to be going to so
as much as i do want them to maintain
the really personal vibe and the family
connection that was the heart of the
first movie between all of yeah these
foster kids living together i also am
excited to see them go into a corner of
mythology i'm not as used to seeing in
superhero movies and even in the lead-up
to watching this video i heard a number
of people at least on twitter saying
like man wonder woman should incorporate
some of this mythology as well yeah so
hopefully maybe this could be an inroad
for more of that in the dcu to further
you know set them apart it's funny how
we had like three
we were the ones who were like there's
some things
i'm
my two big takeaways i think going
forward are this instead of feeling like
an amblin film which the first one
definitely felt like this feels more
like those claymation classic like david
and goliath
like remember those like this feels like
that is the influence and second it does
make sense on the road to black adam
because if black adam2 and shazam three
are one film if shazam three is fighting
black adam you don't want the rock
punching children yeah it's funny
because the the la the last movie was
what was that
i'd
angel he's a nice guy don't punch
astrology that crack in the face thing
that was actually yeah yeah
that's why
yeah you're such a nice guy okay like
the last movie that was what was the it
was jeff john's though there was that
movie was very specifically based on a
very distinct graphic novel yeah and all
they pretty much did was let's take out
black adam yeah
the same exact structure and the way
that bottom fold and then they just like
elevated uh savannah a little bit more
instead of putting black atom in there
so i thought like the natural
progression would be to like yeah let's
get to black adam but yeah it's like
this version of shazam still like shazam
is zachary levi who brings the fun and
the levity uh is that la levites
yeah so he brings he brings out levity
uh where usually even shazam is still
like really serious but you know we'll
see i'm i'm of course going to watch it
opening night and that's not a lie at
the end of the day the three of us
having three different perspectives on
the trailer means it worked because
we're all interested in different things
and that's what you want out of
superhero movies so give me the sword
and sandals shazam 2 with the coolest
costumes by the way i love the costumes
yeah mirror and lucy lip i don't know
what my mentality went down this you
gotta have one trailer where you're kind
of uh skeptical
we got everything excited for it
all right guys thank you so much for
being here thank you koi and uh what do
you guys think though hey let's hunt
this with a
everett pixelmite baker what does pixel
might mean it means that though pixels
may be small they're they're mighty it's
like the might of the the basic building
block how would ever it be pixel might
maybe ever it's like a really small guy
but for his size he's got like super
strength you know oh like an ant you
know like ants are really small but like
as compared to their body they're like
way stronger proportionally speaking
maybe that's everything yeah we'll go
with that we're going with that you're
small but mighty people are like hey man
what's your favorite patriarchy thank
you
what were you gonna say well i was gonna
start on a riff about how like people
are always like walking all over trying
to step over him you know trying to like
you know overlook everett out there in
the world but you know what with the
might of his pixels he's gonna be known
by everybody he's gonna tower above us
despite his stature
and all of this is ironic
yeah
[Music]